outside Vedas Congress hundreds of
police continued to reinforce security
around the buildings only allowing
members of Congress's Permanent
Commission to enter the premises that
loss to be no a rebel lawmaker who
supported swearing-in an interim
president on Monday came under attack
angry Peruvians threw garbage at him a
show of just how disenchanted Peruvians
are with legislators legislators helped
defeat one of their own flee with fake
credentials others gained a seat others
are involved in drug trafficking
there was a mafia of sex offenders in
there this cars decision was good the
worst political crisis in decades has
left Peruvians confused a day after
president Martinez Garin dissolved
Congress the vice president sworn in as
new interim president resigned Mercedes
arouse posted a letter on her Twitter
account saying the Constitutional
Tribunal should decide whether this
Kara's decision to close Congress is
legal watching the drama unfold some
Peruvians say things should have gone in
a different direction
we have to learn to respect the state
powers maybe this will change things
around but why couldn't this car wait
for a year if he couldn't govern he
should have stepped aside critics of
mascara say he's a weak president now
members of the opposition majority say
his Peru's new dictator and his decision
is a coup d'etat surely we will go to
international organizations to protect
our rights but also we will march
alongside Peruvians to recover our
democracy in the middle of this
uncertainty and as the hours go by
president Martinez Kara's position is
consolidating he has the army he has the
police but most importantly he has the
approval of most Peruvians an opinion
poll in May said 71% of Peruvians
disapproved of Congress 63 percent
wanted it closed on Tuesday many said
they felt relieved I'm happy because
finally they brought down the rat's nest
they supported corruption many people
even say they want all those involved in
corrupt
jailed and are hoping marvelous Cara may
deliver that desire if he prevails
Mariana Sanchez al-jazeera Lima Peru